prosecutors in Los Angeles who are
reportedly reviewing eight claims of
sexual misconduct against disgraced
Hollywood producer Harvey Weinstein
according to Variety the LA County DA's
office has been reviewing most of the
allegations for nearly two years it has
not filed any criminal charges Weinstein
faces a trial in New York on January 6
on charges of rape and sexual assault he
denies all allegations of non-consensual
sex CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman
joins us good morning Ricky I think the
question here when you hear about these
new claims is what does or what role do
these new possible charges and claims
play in the trial that's upcoming here
in New York and January well one of
these allegations may play a pivotal
role in the New York case in January
there are eight cases in LA that they
are reviewing but of the eight
there is one that concerns an allegation
by a woman that goes back to February of
2013 in a hotel in Beverly Hills well in
the case in New York beginning on
January 6 the Manhattan DA's office has
said it's going to call what we say are
three prior bad act witnesses that means
other women who are accusers of Harvey
Weinstein who are going to say that
similar things happen to them and of
those three one of them happened at that
Beverly Hills Hotel back in 2013 in
February so an accuser in LA is going to
become a witness in New York
riki we've heard about a tentative
settlement in a civil suit for Weinstein
25 million dollars you won't have to pay
or out of his own pocket or admit any
wrongdoing could this fall apart or is
this a done deal well nothing is ever a
done deal until it is over and what I
mean by that is the judge has to approve
this settlement the victims have to sign
off on this settlement and it's
complicated it's not complicated because
he's not going to admit any wrongdoing
what's complicated is the
mount of money and that there are
plaintiffs who are still out there who
are represented by other lawyers who are
saying okay you other plaintiffs you
want to settle you're settling they
believe for short money because what
you're going to do is become part of all
the group of creditors in the bankruptcy
proceedings and you are not going to
receive what you do so I'm not saying
it's over until it is finally written
down and everybody signs off you have to
remember to in the law there are only a
couple of remedies that plaintiffs have
when something terrible has happened to
them one of them is money one is not an
apology hmm
time's up the group that was founded in
the wake of the allegations calls a
settlement a symptom of a problematic
and broken system riki claimant as
always we thank you Ricky
you